[Musique]
la collaboration avec sylla consiste en
une offre de formation à la
cybersécurité la société sylla utilise
la cyberhaine jeux mis à disposition en
mode saas par airbus à hubert security
[Musique]
e
la cyber âge c'est un terrain de jeu qui
permet d'endosser sans risque
le rôle des hackers ou le rôle des
équipes en charge de la défense ou de la
protection des systèmes plus
concrètement la cyber ange permet de
faire une modélisation réaliste d'un
système d'information représentatif par
exemple d'une entreprise ou d'une
industrie et d'y jouer une activité
réaliste
[Musique]
leur bus souhaité rechercher une pme et
aehi qui avait qui offrait une certaine
agilité dans ce domaine a notamment de
la formation pour airbus et de la
sécurité c'était également la
possibilité de travailler avec un acteur
qui met en place une solution innovante
avec un objectif qui est de former des
effectifs importants la cyber faut
savoir que aujourd'hui nous estimons en
2022 un besoin d'un million et demi de
personnes supplémentaires dans le
domaine des civières sécurité qui sert à
deuxième objectif qui est également
celui d'augmenter la cyber résilience de
la france face aux menaces cyber
et
[Musique]